you know I was up in my prayer Tower
this morning and
funny thing happened
I was talking with
you know who
and he said to tell you that I have to
raise fifteen thousand dollars before
the show's over
or he's gonna call me home
I said what do you mean call me home
what what if I'm not there
should I leave my machine on
anyway I've told you so I've done my
part and you've got to the end of the
show to do your part and that's more
than enough time
it's only 15 grand and you're all rich
1.3 million and you were all poor
I want to thank Paul Hogan for flying
all the way from Down Under to be here
in Hollywood where when we say Throw
Another shrimp on the barbie it means
we're getting rid of our agents